ROB DODSON: All right, so
yeah, this is me, Rob Dodson,
developer advocate here at
the Google's-- thank you.
That's awesome.
As Peter mentioned, I work
on the Polymer project.
My single goal in
life right now is
to get web components into
all of your hot little hands.
And as we were talking
about what sort of sessions
we wanted to do at
this conference,
I was saying I really
want to do something
about actually
building elements.
So I want you guys
to see what it's
like to actually write the code
and work with these things.
What I found
personally is that I'm
hacking on an idea
over the weekend,
or I just wake up late at night,
and I got this thing in my head
and I'm like, I got to
get this out of my head.
I got to see this on screen.
I found that when I'm
working with elements,
it just makes me crazy
super productive.
Because there's a lot of
really cool APIs and services
out there that I want
to play around with,
but it's just a bunch of work
to get them all set up in my app
and plumb it all together and
glue all the bits together.
And when I'm working
with elements,
I can actually take an element
that someone else has created,
which just wraps their
API nice and neat for me
into a little tag.
And I can just bolt
those pieces together.
Kind of like LEGO
building blocks, right?
I can put them together
and get my idea.
I can deconstruct them even
and rearrange the elements
and re-purpose them and use
them in a totally different way.
So, that's what I want to talk
about tonight is how do we
actually use all these
different elements?
I'm going to start my clock here
so I don't run too over time.
What we're going to do is we're
going to build a couple apps.
You guys are actually
watch me do this live,
so fingers crossed
this goes well.
First thing we're
going to do is we're
going to build a
Street View Tour.
So we're going to build
this application that
connects to a back end.
It's going to pull some
data off that back end
and load it into Google Maps.
It's going to show us a
description of the location
that we're looking
at in the map.
And lastly, it's going
to let us explore
the space using a
Street View element.
So that's going to
be mashup number 1.
Mashup number 2 is going to
be a Map Voice Search element,
so it's going to repurpose the
Google Map element that we're
going to use in the first
mashup and use it again
on the second one.
We're going to be
able to search it
using either keyboard
or our voice.
And we're going to get it
running on the phone using
this amazing camera
contraption thing.
So that's what
we're going to do.
I'm just going to hop into code.
If you guys can't see
anything, or if you
see me making
grave mistakes well
I type out code,
please shout it out.
And-- does anybody know how
to make the sidebar bigger
in Sublime?
I don't actually know.
It's OK, you don't
really have to see it.
So what I got here is just a
folder called development--
it's a little hard
to see over there--
and we got an element inside
of here just called map tour--
and you can't see the
folder, but that's cool.
And typically what I do, when
I'm starting any application,
is I create a little
bower.json file.
Inside of here, I
find all the things
that I want to
install into my app--
can the people in
the back of the room
see this, like, sort of kind of?
Yeah, all right.
This is not so good.
So I got a bower.json file here.
And inside, these
are the dependencies
that my app is going to use.
I got Polymer, we got this thing
called X-tag Imports, which
we're talk about
in a little bit.
Google Maps, Polymer
UI Card-- bunch
of really cool different
things that we're
going to bolt together.
And I'm going to cover
each of these individually
as we get to them, so you
don't have to worry about too
much about what's
going on there.
Instead, we're just
going to hop in the map
tour on Bower install.
And that's going to go out.
That's going to
crawl the interwebs.
It's going to grab all
these different things
and drop them into
my application
so I can start using them.
Whoosh, they're all in there.
That's cool.
All right, so I got all the
stuff that I need to use.
Now I'm going to
open this demo HTML
file so you guys can see that.
And first thing I
got to do is I got
to make sure to
load the platform.
A platform layer
is very important.
That's how why we jump our
browser into the future,
so web components work.
Regardless of the
browser that I'm in, once
I drop that one line of
JavaScript within there.
I can start using
web components.
Registering my own
elements using Shadow DOM.
And the first thing
that I'm going
to do, now that I have
these superpowers,
is I'm going to import
the rest the Polymer.
I'm going to do this
using an HTML import.
So I'm using a
little link tag here.
And I grab polymer/polymer.html.
Any time I start
any Polymer project,
I typically just stud
out really quickly
like a simple Polymer element
that just says, "Hello world."
I'm just going to clean
this guy up a bit.
So the thing that we're
building is a little map tour.
And inside, I've got a
little template tag here.
Whatever I put into
that template tag, when
the browser sees my new
element on the page,
it's just going to grab the
stuff out of the template tag
and render it for me.
So to verify that Polymer
is set up correctly,
I'll just do Hello world.
This is really simple.
This is the most basic Polymer
element that you can write.
And hover into my browser.
Go to local host 8080.
And-- OK, see, I do
this all the time.
I didn't actually use the
thing after I'd find it.
Lesson number one, do that.
Use the tag.
OK.
There we go.
All right, thank you, for small
miracles, please, thank you.
So we got our map tour showing
up, it says "Hello world."
That's kind of not the
most fun thing ever.
If I go back to the requirements
for my really cool mashup,
number one is I got to
connect to a back end service.
So, a show of hands.
How many of you have ever
seen or used Firebase before?
Some of you?
OK.
So for those of you
who haven't, Firebase
is this really cool service.
You can basically upload some
.json to it and it'll create
a little end point for you.
And then you can
later on be like, hey,
give me that .json back.
Just request it and it'll
send it right back to you.
So, I've got a little
collection here called "views."
There's only one
item inside of it,
but it's got a
little bit of data.
It's got some latitude and
longitude for a location
on a map that I want to
load into the Google eMaps.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to pull this data
off Firebase and I'm
going to get it into my app.
And naturally, I know all
of your brains right now,
they're going to $.ajax.
You're like, ah, OK, I know
how he's going to do this.
But that's not how
we're going to do this.
We're actually going
to use an element
that the team created
called core-ajax.
So I think you guys saw a
little bit of this earlier.
So core-ajax is a
custom element that
allows you to do XMLHttpRequest
completely declaratively just
using an HTML tag.
So we're going to--
actually, before we
do that, we're going to
grab this whole map tour
thing that we've been building,
and we're going to turn it
into its own file,
maptour.html, and I
apologize if this is
a little hard to see.
You can ignore this part.
map-tour HTML.
I'm going to grab Polymer.
This is really like
the standard way
that you want to build
your custom elements.
You want to build them in
their own little HTML file
that you import into your demo.
So that way when
someone in Bower
installs your element later,
they can just link to it.
So we're going to
grab maptour.html.
So what that's
doing is that's just
grabbing this little file
over here that I created.
This is where we're actually
going to build our element.
So you're going to verify
things are good still,
still says "Hello world."
Rad.
OK.
Now I mentioned we're
going to use core-ajax.
Let's just import that guy.
Core-ajax.
And the way you can
figure core-ajax
is pretty straightforward.
First, you can give
it an auto attribute,
and that's going to say,
hey, anytime this tag-- like,
the parser hits it
or something-- just
go out and make HTTP
request on my behalf.
I don't want to have to call
a method to tick you off,
I just want you
to do your thing.
And as for where
to go, I'm going
to grab this URL from Firebase.
Drop that guy in
there, and we're
going to ask for the
views.json object.
And when that data comes
back from Firebase,
I'm going to create
a little scope
variable for it called "views."
What?
Oh, thank you-- you guys
are good, thank you.
Whoever said that
gets all the stickers.
OK.
Did I do it again?
Wait, what?
Response-- response.
OK, all right, response.
OK, so data comes back.
I create a scope
variable called "views."
And now that's going
to be available
throughout my element.
Anybody can now bind
to this "views" object
and play around with this
collection that just came back
from Firebase.
So I'm going to just
write h1 one here,
and I want viewsviews[0].name,
and we'll also get
views[0].latitude.
So this is just the data that
I have in Firebase there.
I refresh the page, and
I see Heron Island, -23.
And I go back to
Firebase, and that
is the name of the
location on the map
that we're trying to get
into our application.
OK, cool, so I didn't write
any JavaScript by the way,
and we just completed the
first line of our mash up here.
We connected to a back
end service, we got data,
and we loaded it into our app.
The next thing I
need to do is I need
to get into the Google Maps.
And you guys have seen the
Google Maps element a fair bit.
If you actually want
to play around with it,
it's up on GitHub at
polymerlabs/google-map.
Please go grab it and
mess around with it,
it's a lot of fun.
And in my editor, I'm
just going to import
google-map/google-map.html.
Remember, all these things just
came from that bower.json file
that I installed from earlier.
So that's where they're
magically appearing from.
So instead of grabbing
a name and latitude
and just dropping
that into h1, I'm
going to drop it into
Google map element.
So it wants latitude.
This guy, it's
latitude, but thank you
for-- if you guys were trying
to save me from myself.
And it wants longitude.
And I just know
later on I'm going
to need to expose the map
property for Street View,
so I'm going to go ahead and
do that so I don't forget.
And we got to write just
a tiny bit of JavaScript
here-- or, sorry, CSS here to
style the Google Maps element
so it looks nice on our page.
And I set its display to
block and its height to 100%.
So you got data coming from
Firebase into core-ajax,
and then from core-ajax, it
goes into our Google Map.
Swap back over to our page.
Refresh.
And, whoa, there we go.
So we got a Google map here.
It's a little hard to see,
like, where is Heron island?
I'm not quite sure.
So, I'm just going to
add one more attribute.
Show center marker.
And, OK, so these attributes
and everything that I'm adding?
These are just part of
the Google Maps' API,
but the element has given
me a nice declarative
way of playing around with them.
I don't have to get in there
and write a configuration object
and specifically pass it into
the constructor of Google Maps,
right?
I can just say, hey, show
me the center marker.
I get it.
OK.
So that's really exciting.
I like that.
So we got this thing
appearing in Google Maps.
Now I want to do a little
crazy interrupt thing here.
I want to make Polymer
work with x-tags.
I want to actually use both
of them in the same project.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take our Google Map,
and I'm going to kind of create
like a Grand Theft Auto style
heads-up display.
I go ahead and I take the map,
and I put it into a little cart
down in the bottom
corner of my site.
And then I'm going to drop in a
Street View element after that,
so that way when you're like
in the Street View element,
you have the map showing
you where you're at.
So, to do that, we've
got another element here
from the Polymer team
called Polymer UI card.
We're going to actually
put our map inside of.
I don't if that comes through
super clear on the projector,
but Polymer UI cards
are really nice.
You get these cool,
swipeable Google Now cards.
So I'm going to just
import Polymer UI card.
And I should mention,
after I get this card in,
I'm going to put it
inside of an x-tag.
So when I drop it inside of
this x-tag called FlipBox.
So FlipBox, as Daniel
probably mentioned earlier,
shows you how to toggle
these things back and forth.
You get these cool
3D flipping effects.
So I'm going to put two
cards inside of here.
The first one is
going to show my map
and the other
one's going to show
an actual description
of Heron island.
This place-- this mythical place
that we're trying to visualize.
So you got your Polymer UI
card, and I'm just going to say,
the Polymer UI card--
and the nice thing
is I can just scoot
the map up in there.
And I am going to have to
write a tiny bit of CSS
to position this
thing, and this is
the last CSS I'm going to write.
And, let's see, so
we want our card
to have the width
and height of 275.
And we give it some padding.
And for position, absolute.
And we're going to put it
in the bottom left hand
corner of our site.
So the other part
here-- semi-colon!
Ah, man.
Thanks guys.
OK, so we got our card here.
And I believe-- OK, now I know
the projector's messing me
up right now.
Projector's trying
to wreck my game.
So I'm going scoot this
guy in-- or maybe he's not.
Well, you can see that.
OK, cool.
He can see that.
It was cut off during
the earlier demo.
See that guy?
OK.
What's up?
Oh, OK, oh, shit.
Well the science really
wrecking my game.
All right, for you
sign people, here
look it's over there, OK,
or look at that projector.
OK.
So we got our card down there,
but I mentioned FlipBox, right?
I want to flip this
thing back and forth.
Wanted to do some cool stuff.
So we've been working-- myself
and some of the guys on X-tag's
been working on this project
called x-tag imports, which
actually let you import
x-tags using HTML imports.
Sorry, this is the better URL.
That's my port.
That's the URL you want.
x-tag/x-tag-imports.
So I'm going to import FlipBox.
So
x-tag-imports/x-tag-flipbox.html.
Drop that guy.
Basically like the same thing
that we did to the card itself.
And the Google Map-- we
want to move the Google Map
into the Polymer UI card.
Then we're going to
take that whole thing
and move it into a FlipBox.
And yeah, the name x-flipbox
is different from the import,
but that's by design.
OK, so now we just like scooted
this card up into the FlipBox,
right?
That's kind of cool.
And we're going to
write another Polymer UI
card for the back space.
And we're just going to
give us a div description,
and use another binding.
And we're still using this data
object coming from Firebase.
So I got my view and what
I want is its description.
And maybe we'll drop
the name in there
as well so people know what
heck they're looking at.
Mm, that looks good.
It's looking good.
Should I be binding to the
description on the map?
Oh, yeah, that's cool.
No, no, yes.
That's on purpose, yes.
So, we see this guy,
what we're going to get
is-- we need to write a
little bit of Javascript
to tell FlipBox that
homie's gotta flip.
So we're going to give
it a little bit of an ID.
And we're going to say on-tap.
Anytime anybody clicks on you, I
want you to do your flip thing.
Down here in my
prototype, doflip.
So what I'm doing
here is I'm actually
just referring to FlipBox.
I'm referring to it's ID
with this .$.flipbox.toggle.
Oh, oh, wait, wait,
timeout, timeout.
We also need a little CSS.
There we go.
So we got our little
card down there
with the name now showing.
When I click on it, I get
this rad flipping effect.
So you can see, oh,
cool, OK, so now
I know what the heck
Heron island is.
Great.
Oh, I don't-- oh, sorry,
I didn't want it to remain
on the back face.
I wanted it to be
hidden on the back face.
But, yes, you're right.
If I wanted it to
remain in both places,
I would put the
h3 on both cards.
OK, so this is like the
world's most boring application
that I've ever built.
It could do so much more.
So the last thing
that I want to do
is I'm going to go
to customelements.io.
And, by the way, I recommend
if you guys haven't been there
yet, please check it out
and play around with it,
because there's so much
cool stuff on there.
Like every time I go to
customelements.io, I'm like,
I want to build an app.
And I just start like
finding cool things on here,
and I'm like, yeah,
I want that one too,
and that one and that one.
And I just start bolting
them together, kind of
like a mad scientist.
So there's an element
here that I've
got called Google Map
Street View panorama.
I'm sorry that it has
the longest name ever.
I'm probably going to rename it.
So what it does is
it bundles up the API
for working in Street View.
So I'm just going
to import this guy.
google-map-streetview-panorama.
We're definitely going
to copy and paste that.
.html, Google Maps-- OK, OK.
And, up here, drop
in into a tag.
Wrap that guy.
And we got to make sure to
bind to the map property
that we exposed earlier
from our Google Map
down here so that we
know that maps uploaded.
And if we go back and
we look at Firebase,
there's all these things
in here like heading,
and panoid, and pitch.
Things that we need to use
inside of this element.
So, we're going to bind
panoid="viewspanoid="views[0]panoid".
And we'll do our heading.
Wow, that was crazy.
We'll do zoom-- I
mean, it was helpful,
but crazy-- we'll do pitch.
OK, heading, zoom,
pitch, panoid, map.
Let's cross our fingers.
Let's see what we get.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God, we got a sea turtle!
OK.
Yay.
There was less rejoicing.
OK.
So, yeah, Heron Island, a
coral cay in the Great Barrier
Reef featuring sea turtles.
Right?
So this is actual Street View.
You can play around
with this guy.
You can see that he's actually
got this other sea turtle.
He's like stealthing on him
and about to steal his stuff.
So there's a lot of
really cool stuff
that you can do just
wiring together elements.
Like, I wrote-- we wrote-- this
is our only line of JavaScript
really, right?
And the rest of this--
yeah, thank you--
and the rest of this
was just elements.
We're describing things,
wiring them together.
Building blocks, right?
OK, so thus concludes the
hair raising text editor
live coding portion of the talk.
Now we move on to the designer.
So we're going to build this
Map Voice Search thing using
the designer tool that you
guys have seen earlier.
So let's see-- localhost:9000.
All right, so this is
the current gen version
of our designer tool.
I'm going to make sure you
guys can see that real good.
All right.
Can you guys see that
good on both projectors?
OK, got it.
All right.
Current generation version
of the designer tool I'm
going to drop a scaffolding
element onto the page.
I'm going to click this
little button to make it fit.
So the scaffold element
gives me, really,
like the bare bones of
a responsive website.
I get a sidebar
that'll collapse for me
if the viewport is too small.
Got a content area where I
can just drop things into.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to
grab a Google Map.
My old friend, Google
Map, he's back.
Again, this is the
same Google Map element
that we were just working with.
If you look down here
in the bottom left hand
corner-- this guy
right here, Google Map?
Same dude, right?
But this time we just
dropped him onto the page.
And what I want
to happen is when
I click these
buttons over here, I
want to change between roadmap
view and satellite view.
So the way we're
going to do that is
we're going to grab
these guys, we're
going to change their labels,
roadmap, and satellite,
and maybe we'll give them
really cool markers, too.
Those markers suck.
There we go.
All right, it's
looking nicer now.
OK, so I've got two buttons
here, and i got a map,
but they're not talking yet.
I want them to actually
talk to each other.
So if you hop over to the
code view for the editor--
I'll try to load
that up for you guys
so you can see it a bit better.
So you got these
core items here.
This is what I've been
dropping onto my canvas, right?
Roadmap, satellite, et cetera.
And if you look, we're actually
inside of a Polymer element.
The only thing that we're doing
inside of this designer tool
is we're just building
one big Polymer element.
And so that means we can use
all the features in Polymer
in this code editor.
So I can say, hey, on-tap,
I want you to show the road.
On-tap, show the satellite.
And then down here in the
prototype for our element,
we're just going to say
showRoad is a function,
showSet is a function, and we're
just going to tell the Google
Map element to set its
mapType = 'roadmap'.
And click on satellite,
set satellite.
A caller function?
That's what-- On-tap, do
I need a caller function?
No, I don't.
This guy right here.
Yeah, it's a declarative
event binding,
so whatever I pass
it right here,
it's just going to trigger
that on my prototype anytime
someone actually
touches the element.
So, if we save it,
we can actually
click this guy and
preview it over here.
And now I click satellite,
I get satellite view
and I get the real map view.
Resize the page and I get
responsiveness for free.
Which is pretty rad, right?
And If I take this
phone over here--
So I got a phone, and what
I'm going to try to do
is preview this over here.
So I'm going to take this
URL, open the DevTools
and say, Inspect Device.
We're using port forwarding
to forward the port
that this is running
on to our device.
There we go.
Man, it's like taking a nap.
All right, let's see.
Oh, we so don't have
port forwarding.
That's cool, we can fix that.
Oh, was there?
Yeah.
Oh, shit, dude-- OK, thank you.
Thanks man.
Yes!
Oh, my God.
I love all of you.
All right, yes.
Sweet.
OK, this thing-- whoa, hey,
check it out-- so here's
my app running on the phone.
And all I did was
open up the tab
that I was working with
over here on the device.
And click on it, switch to
satellite mode, hit back,
roadmap.
Cool, right?
OK, so now I'm using
this designer tool,
and actually like
constructing a mobile app.
I'm not even writing
any code to do this.
So, the last trick
that I want to do
is I want to add voice
search to this whole process.
So we're going to go
back to our designer.
Enhance-- there we go.
And I want to be able to
search for a location.
So I'm going to drop
a field up in here.
And we're going to just drop
that up in the top left corner.
Because this is just
an HTML element,
I can actually change its style.
So I can set its
background color to white.
Now you can actually
see it up there.
And I need to bind
that field to the map,
and I'm going to use another
element to do this for me.
To do the heavy lifting.
So I've got an element here
called Google Maps search.
It's a non-visual element,
so I drop it on the screen.
You're not going to
see anything update.
But over here In the
Properties Inspector,
I've got these two
new properties.
Map and query.
If I combine those two,
the Google Map element,
find its map property,
find the query
to the core input, which
is the input field up here.
And then my Google
Map element, I'm
going to tell it to bind
to the search element
that I just dropped on the page.
So latitude is Google
Map search latitude--
wait, result.latitude.
Longitude.
Google Map search
result.longitude.
And zoom is 18.
And I'm going to also turn
off the UI for Google Maps,
because it's like,
getting in that way.
So if I switch to satellite mode
now, and save it, preview it.
So hop into satellite mode.
And looks like-- check
out the Eiffel Tower.
Whoosh.
All right, so now
we're in Paris.
We're looking at the Eiffel
Tower, which is beautiful.
But you know, we're building
a mobile app, right?
And typing with
these gigantic hands,
it's like impossible on a phone.
So I would prefer if I could
use Voice Search to do this.
So we're going to go
back to our editor.
We're going to grab this
little speech-like element
and just drop it
into our input field.
And we're going to go to our
core input and bind its value
to that speech_mic--
speech_mic.transcript.
So now anytime I talk
into the microphone,
it goes to the core input.
That gets piped to Google
Maps search, which gets
piped to the Google Map itself.
OK?
You guys following that chain?
So I'm going to save this.
Preview it.
Should be able to look
at this on the phone.
What?
Oh, fuck.
Don't steal my phone, OK?
You will all be confiscated
as you leave this event.
Oh, my God, that's super funny.
All right.
Well, anyway, guys, the
microphone's here, so,
hold-- OK.
So, please, the microphone.
Stop laughing, because you
got to be really quiet,
because we're going
to try to do this.
Roman Colosseum.
Yeah, what's up!
OK.
Holy shit.
Peter, I'm sorry I
swore so much on stage.
OK, so, I wanted you guys
to get a feel for what
it is to actually work
with these elements.
Like I don't want to
do a high-level talk.
I want you guys to
actually see these things,
because this is going
to be the future.
This is going to be the
improved developer ergonomics
that I think a lot
of us are after.
So, please go check out
the Polymer website.
Hit us up on @Polymer
on the Twitters.
You can find all
my information--
oh, wait-- find all the
information on this slide right
here.
Thank you guys so
much for coming out
and definitely stick
around for the QA.